I come to you from my kitchen
as a woman who did not listen to those diabolical lies.
I went to college,
but it was only to find my missus degree,
only to find my husband
and the man that would be able to help me find my true calling
of becoming a wife and mother.
And I did that at 24 years old.
I found him. We got married at 26 and immediately started having kids.
My first child was born at 27 years old.
I still felt a little old,
but I was excited to get started.
And my true happiness.
We went on to have children every two years for four children total.
And even though one of them was disabled,
I chose against abortion and I kept my baby.
I loved and served my family every single day.
Until I woke up and realized the fucking lies were that.
That would make me happy.
And now, 15 years later,
I'm finally using my college degree.
Yesterday was my first day on the job using my fucking college degree.
And I went to bed
feeling so much more fulfilled than I ever thought was possible.
The joy in my heart to know that I did know myself.
I knew what the fuck I wanted.
I knew what I was doing.
And I was lying to myself
by thinking that I could be this mousey little princess
that just sits behind closed doors and supports another man
for Him to achieve all of his dreams.
That's the fucking diabolical lie.
I hope every single woman in the graduating class of 2024
and every year after that.
Follows their dream in their heart and finds true happiness.
Because being a mother is not all that you are created for.